one thing I noticed and Rob Highland the
producer of football night in America
pointed this out in the viewing room
last night
we could hear Kirk Cousins throughout
the game when he was calling the signals
he sounded like and this is before your
time he sounded like Peter Brady in the
episode of The Brady Bunch voice was his
voice was kind of baby he's finally gone
through puberty maybe this is a good
sign for Kirk Cousins and the Vikings
maybe something's dropped for him and
now they can go on and give the 49ers
everything I can handle I was stunned we
bought a course of all the games this
weekend the one you and I were the most
certain of was the New Orleans Saints in
a class above the Minnesota Vikings a
Saints shouldn't have even been playing
in the wild-card round they should have
had a buy and there's questions we're
not they were the best team right now in
the NFL yeah and the Vikings kind of
slumbered down the stretch the game
against the Packers on the monday night
two weeks ago that was for both of us
the moment where we just kind of
scratched him off it's like yeah we were
wrong they're not ready with or without
the Alvin cook they're not gonna be able
to get this done and holy crap they got
it done they got it done
first off awesome for Kirk Cousins it
just tells you like how the the team
actually realizes what he's going
through - they were happy for him that's
why I love seeing that moment in the
locker room it's made me laugh like
three times over the last 24 hours
but you know I think the game when I
look at it of course curse cousins big
throws is huge
there's three things that it did jump
out to me about the game one the early
turnover and the Saints only getting a
field goal - the Saints up ten six
before the half and we're going oh there
looks like they're gonna put a drive and
maybe a school before the half drew
Brees throws the interception the
Vikings score the touchdown the Saints
then go down and missed the field goal
before the half that was a huge momentum
swing right there - where we went into
halftime going whoa the Vikings are in
this and they're winning and they're
about to get the ball in the second half
and then of course the end of the game
Daniel hunter sack fumble it was 2017
Vikings still I get it but there was six
minutes left I felt like that maybe 24
20 exactly I felt like it inevitable it
was gonna be 20 20 and they were gonna
kick a field goal and Minnesota was
gonna go three now and the Saints were
gonna get the ball back with good time
to go down and kick the game-winning
field
I just felt like that was gonna happen
but the Vikings made place and the
Saints didn't and here we are and now
the Vikings your Minnesota Vikings how
many times do I have to tell you it's
Danielle you keep wanting to say
Danielle oh sorry yeah Neil I'm bad
sorry didn't know but but you know that
was the one where yes drew brees just
kind of dropped the ball in his hand and
Hunter got him and the ball squirted out
you know what they did they brought
Daniel hunter and Everson Griffin inside
and Mike Zimmer the coach of the Viking
explained after game he's just decided
to try something a little bit different
I'm zit works sometimes it does may take
room it worked on Ryan push up the
middle right push up the middle and you
know Drew Brees has struggled against
the Vikings the last three times he's
played them he got over 200 passing
yards yesterday and it kind of woke up
for them in the second half yeah but but
it look III want to be very respectful
everything drew Brees is accomplished
and a couple of weeks ago after he had
that 29 430 performance and became the
all-time leader in passing touchdowns we
did our top 10 all-time ranking and I
got him at five and you got him at nine
or ten or something like that yeah but
let me tell you the best player on the
field yesterday for either team was
Taysom Hill yes
the Vikings couldn't try to tackle him
right the Vikings didn't know how to
cover him why didn't they get him on the
field more is there some kind of weird
quarterback politics going on here where
we got to be respectful of drew we can't
use Taysom Hill too much even though
maybe he's a better option well I mean
yeah Drew Brees is a legend yeah so I
think that Sean Payton realizes that
would probably ruffle his feathers if
he's out of the game too much or being
taken out of too many parts of the
football game in general I I do yes
you know taste him he'll I do think he's
the future and waiting you're right Mike
I mean Taysom Hill or Dalvin cook were
the two best players on the field
Taysom Hill was phenomenal no matter
what he did and I think the big thing is
you know he was the one tactical
advantage they showed they had during
the game you know the one thing Mike
Zimmer and I'm really excited to watch
this film because I think Mike Zimmer
changed some things up on defense
you know usually he's kind of like a
creature of habit I run these two three
long few years ago right after they got
blasted by the Eagles right he said
maybe we need to go back and look at
what we've I remember those boats right
and chand change it up more in the post
yeah right and I feel like yesterday and
again it's hard to tell on TV
sometimes but you know two things jumped
out to me we didn't see a lot of Michael
Thomas especially like over the middle
those are usually when Sean Payton can
game plan you to death and just find the
matchups no album chimera in the past
game really no Jared cook with like huge
numbers so that tells me there was
things being done to take away that
short to intermediate pass game that the
Saints love and then as we saw for
really the second playoffs in a row we
were sitting there watching the game
going they can't really push the ball
down the field they can't really back
Minnesota off we've except would take
some health right we would see Minnesota
dbe's
sitting on everything and I remember
coach Dungy at one point six they got to
throw it over their head I mean they're
sitting on everything and it became a
problem for the Saints one of the things
about the Vikings offense and you're
right Dalvin cook had a great game he's
healthy and as long as he's healthy the
Vikings are going to be competitive yeah
but and and you know I don't I don't
know why I'm I'm treading lightly here
yeah wise kevin Stefanski a head coach
in candy well I don't know why you and I
have had this conversation Kevin look
that toss sweep yeah that's like a kid
playing Madden who discovered a play
that worked once and he uses it all the
time the toss sweep was not working toss
sweep is not something that you just
said you know we're gonna do it every
other play there has to be a little bit
of an element of surprise to it when
you're doing it repeatedly look how many
times he got shut down it was a heck of
a bell to me they got lucky on that play
where Dalvin cook Snee hit just before
the ball popped up right here but then
they used it again down to the goal line
in overtime forced him into that third
and goal from the five that that you
know but for the Kyle Rudolph catch and
we need to talk about whether or not
that was passing yeah we're gonna get
into it but that that you know that
could have given the Saints a shot at
the ball but tear up the toss sweep only
use it when you've got them set up from
running it up the middle where they're
gonna be focused on stop isn't that I'm
gonna tell you I'm wrong it is the
defense is focused on crashing into the
middle Ryan you sneak around the outside
no I think I mean you're right as far as
I think you're you know what you saw
yesterday you're you're spot-on I think
the big thing is you know early on they
were they were gashing him on the edge
with some of those edge runs off tackle
runs the toss sweep a few of those
things the book on the New Orleans
Saints defense
is to run on the edge cuz you and I have
talked about so many times this year how
big they are up front it's one of the
best run stopping defenses in football
so you know I think it was one of those
things where they kind of stayed with
what their game plan thought was maybe a
little too long but regardless Dalvin
cook being healthy it's just again once
shows you they're a different football
team when he's close to healthy or when
he can just put his you know put the
pedal to the metal of the way he did
yesterday I mean he just he's got a he's
got two Rockets up his butt I mean as
soon as the game started you went holy
cow he's the fastest guy in the field I
forgot how fast he was with you know
this injury he's been dealing with so
not only was he awesome but then of
course wanted to do yes it filtered down
to the rest of the offense Kirk Cousins
more eventually eventually it took a
little while yeah and then they're doing
with his cutesy stuff right it's working
Dalvin cook Dalvin cook Alexander
Madison Dalvin cook Dalvin cook
Alexander Madison and then they do the
double reverse pass that and they let
Stefon Diggs try to throw it again when
he badly overthrew Kirk Cousins a couple
of weeks ago and I'm like what are you
doing don't and this and we've seen this
time and again and this isn't a specific
criticism of Kevin Stefanski but these
offensive coordinators they're in
consideration for head coaching jobs
they're trying to impress people with
the plays they've drawn up that are just
doing what works and and it and it could
have contributed to the Vikings not
being in a 13 to 10 lead and halftime or
or it could have allowed the Vikings to
not have to screw around with overtime
and just win the thing convincingly in
in regulation I don't want to be overly
critical with a guy I mean he's been
with the Vikings for years he said you
know he's survived and he's thrived and
he's grown and at some point I guess
he's gonna be a head coach but I just I
tell you I'm the biggest difference for
the Vikings this year is Gary Kubiak
well I examine said it multiple times I
think that's the perplexing thing about
Stefanski and the head coaching search
and all that yes I think he's got you
know the what do I want to say the
presence and the charisma to be that
head coach do I think he needs to grow
offensively more yes when we talk about
the strengths of the Minnesota Vikings
offense they're not kevin Stefanski
things they're Gary Kubiak things were
talking about
so I Szymanski is one of those guys may
be best served if he stayed there
another year they get another weapon on
offense and he shows that his offense
can continue to grow be explosive and
then maybe he gets whatever job he
all right the car route off but let's
get into him right now and and I think
it was past interference okay and I
think that what what do you always say
rubbing his race rubbing is racing and
and I think the Vikings and Kyle Rudolph
keenly aware almost like we dare you to
drop this flag we dare your to overturn
this fear we are a review you're not
gonna do it right right not gonna do it
and and they'd and they got it right
it's a touchdown right but but look
there's the push the head goes back yeah
clearly offensive pass interference
right but it wasn't called so it's not
right well sir I don't look at it again
I'm more on the rubbing is racing on
this play you know again I can't sit
here and go oh I really feel like that's
offensive pass interference did he push
off there yeah he did but I know PJ
Williams grabbed him before he pushed
off so again and you know you talked
about the gloves all the time how sticky
they are it doesn't take much to grab
somebody with those gloves you don't
need to be like straining to be like oh
I gotta hold your arms it's a normal
little like hey I'm holding your arm and
you're locked in there pretty good or
you got a piece of the Jersey so that's
where I would just argue back a little
bit especially like that first clip and
we could just start from the beginning
of what we just show there look the
hands go on right Rudolph Furst he's oh
oh he's bushes well he's never gonna be
able to do anything if the other guys
allowed to hold him and he just has to
stand there so that that to me the
contact is initiated by the same pyre so
if we're gonna do it I don't know it
mean Minnesota guy can sit there and
just go look he's got his hands on me I
won't even try to push off or do
anything it's fast interference but he
he pushed off I don't disagree with that
but I do not I think that maybe when our
ever on looks at it yeah because in the
pool report that he provided after the
game he mentioned there was mutual
contact right he can't call defensive
holding or illegal contact by the
defensive player via replay review and
really if they had it's offsetting fouls
and you do it again Yeah right you just
say forget it we're not gonna do
anything we're gonna let it go period
but the thing that is stunning about it
when we look at the full scope of the
season yeah back in June when our Veron
met with employees of NFL media he
showed them the Mike Williams push off
week 15 of the
2018 season Chiefs Chargers and it was
the same motion the same thing and
because that play was ruled defensive
pass interference and River on surprised
everybody by saying you know what the
end result would have been offsetting
fouls because there's not enough to
overturn the ruling of dpi but there
also was OPI yeah in Mike Williams doing
that and that's what we saw right he saw
Kyle Rudolph doing that but last play of
the game I dare you to call it sure and
that's when you understand how the rules
get applied Mike Zimmer you know they
asked him about it after the game he's
like I saw two feet down I saw the ball
in his hands and I got the hell out of
there and you know that's that's one of
the benefits of that happening the last
play of the game everybody's gone before
there's a chance to really do anything
about it I think it puts even more
praise I'm more of a dare I dare you our
I triple dog dare you Wow River on to
overturn it and he wasn't gonna do well
no I you know I don't think he is and
you know again this is something that
we're gonna continue to hear about and
through the playoffs this is gonna be a
conference because we're gonna have a
call this weekend that's gonna come down
at the end of the game and like you've
always said 50 people in a bar and 25 or
30 we're gonna go that's fast
interference and then 25 or 30 you know
I think it was it wasn't so we're gonna
have this issue because of this rule and
that replay review is available for this
here's the thing yeah and I know that
it's not gonna be there's not enough
games for many apples-to-apples
comparisons yeah but but what we saw
yesterday is precedent for the remaining
postseason James right and they need to
be consistent with what happened
yesterday to the extent there's
something similar to what happened
yesterday and one of these remaining
game well yes and I think other than a
two or three week period they were
consistent this whole year I mean that
to me goes back to what we've started
the year as right and what we've gotten
to maybe the last week or two I know
about like week twelve or thirteen we
went through a phase where we went the
bars here the bears legit right now now
they're back to we're going in the call
if it's totally egregious and we feel
like it and to me that was rubbing his
racing and I also think the circumstance
that the game had I agree with they
dared him to call it up and he didn't
I'm not making any any comments on that
other than you know I've I've told you
guys this for the last you know couple
years and I've always just taken it one
year at a time and and kind of
reevaluate each offseason and then you
know find the things I want to get
better at they're all sort of tells that
people have and the nervous smile is a
tell yeah because that's not a
circumstance to be smiling your season
ends after a great run in over time that
smile isn't because he's happy that
smile is because the question of Jerry's
future struck to the heart of his
reality he's gonna be a free agent
yeah he was a free agent two years ago
after Minneapolis miracle there was
never any real talk about him leaving
but now you've got Taysom Hill yeah who
was the best Saint on the field if not
the best player on the field for either
team right and Drew Brees gonna be 41 in
nine days right at some point you know
not every guy's gonna walk away on his
own terms at some point the team is
gonna be the one to say we got to do
something
Taysom Hill he's 29 he's gonna be a
restricted free agent the most they
could apply is that that first round
tender that you know there could be
somebody out there saying hey everybody
wants a Lamar Jackson there's a little
more Jackson why he's running for the
New Orleans Saints right they are gonna
make them the starter we will well if
you listen to anybody who knows anything
in the NFL a lot of people will tell you
that Sean Payton's excited to run that
type of offense would taste him he'll
he's the guy in waiting so yeah they
need to do their due diligence here I
mean we're getting very close your
breeze is still real good we know that
but can he overcome the great defenses
and pay off football and stuff like that
I don't know I think that's a real
question
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports